yes so we're going to talk about L-functions. I want to give you an example
first of all of one L-function that I
think you probably would recognize and
this is the Riemann zeta function, which
depends on a complex number
s is x+iy. 'i' here is the square root
of -1, and you can define it either by
a sum over the integers, all the integers, all the positive ones. Or, this is a great discovery of Euler:
I can write it as a product over the
prime numbers. and so the zeta function
encodes information about the primes. It
contains all the primes and if you can
unravel how the information in the zeta function is encoded you can determine
properties of the primes. That's one of
the L-functions, and let me tell you
a little bit more about the Riemann zeta
function because that's gonna be part of the
story. So the Riemann zeta function is
defined as a sum over the integers or a
product over the primes, and these
formuli work if x is greater than one.
But it turns out you can find formuli
that match these when x is greater than 1.
When x is less than one work as well.
And here's what the Riemann zeta function
looks like. So these formuli work to the
right of the line x=1. So they work
out here. And they tell you the value of
the zeta function anywhere in this in this
region. Now it turns out the zeta function has this amazing symmetry
which was discovered by Riemann, which say that
the line that I have drawn in blue there
that passes though the point one half, that's
a symmetry line of the Riemann zeta
function. If I know the value the zeta
function at some point here, I reflect
that point through the blue line to get
a point here and know its value here. I can deduce that very easily. So Riemann reflection
formula, the symmetry formula, tells us
that because I know he zeta
function in this range I also know in
this range as the reflection so that
just leaves this strip which we don't
understand. This trip is where the
function is really mysterious. We know that in this strip,
there are infinitely many points where the zeta function takes the value 0.
The belief is - and this is the Riemann
hypothesis - that these points where the
Zetas function
takes the value zero, all lie exactly on
the symmetry line, and this is called the
Riemann hypothesis. And this is one of
the great mysteries of mathematics.
Riemann hypothesized this in 1859 and it's
been tested hugely since.
BRADY: professor, it's well-known in mathematics that if any mathematician can prove the
Riemann hypothesis, he or she is destined
for greatness.
PROF: Yeah. BRADY: Why?
PROF:  Well, because the Riemann zeta
function encodes information about the
prime, so if we know the positions of the
zeros, that tells us really important
information about the prime numbers.
BRADY: What information? What does it tell you that you don't already know?
PROF: it tells us things we already suspect, because we sort of
believe the Riemann hypothesis is true, but there are things we can't prove. So for example,
how many primes are there up to a trillion? We have a formula that we believe is true but we
can only prove that formula if we know
the Riemann hypothesis is true.
BRADY: So it's like a whole bunch of houses would suddenly have a foundation. PROF: Absolutely,
and there are whole books written assuming the
truth of the Riemann hypothesis,
so the foundations of our understanding of the primes would disappear if the Riemann
hypothesis turned out to be false. It's
known there are infinitely many zeros of the
Riemann zeta function inside the
critical strip, and it's known that at
least 40% of those do lie on the
symmetry line. It is known, and this is a
result of hugely extensive computations
that the first 10 trillion zeros
lie exactly on the symmetry line. That's the first ten thousand billion. It's known that
batches of zeros, much higher up, beyond the 10 trillion, lie on the line,
so I think the world record at the moment is there's a batch of zeros up beyond the 10^36th zero,
That is the billion billion
billion billion-th zero, somewhere up there
there's a whole batch which we know
lie exactly on the line, so people have put a
pretty huge effort into this, and there's
a long history of this:
Alan Turing, when he built the first electronic
computer, one of the first things he did
was compute the zeros of the zeta function. He found about the first 1000 lie on the line.
BRADY: professor, if a mathematician one day finds a zero in the strip but not on the line,
is that mathematician gonna be a hero or a pariah?
PROF: [laughs] Well they would certainly be very famous, and I think mathematicians
very sanguine about this, they'll just accept the truth, they want to know the
truth, that person would be famous,
but I think it would be a kind of
ugly kind of fame, not a beautiful kind of fame.
So we got these properties and this is what I want to emphasize: we can write the zeta
function as a sum over the integers,
or as a product over the primes,
and the zeta function has a symmetry line, reflection symmetry line,
and we believe that all the zeros of the zeta function around that line
lie exactly on that. This is one of the great
mysteries in mathematics, and people have
spent 150-odd years
thinking about this. And one natural way
if you're given a mystery is to try to
understand: well, is this a more general
property? So are there other functions which look like the Riemann zeta function?
And maybe by finding lots of those functions and comparing them that tells you the
essential properties that make the
Riemann hypothesis true. Maybe it allows
us to prove it. So an example would be:
if you think about evolution,
Darwin wanted to establish evidence for
evolution, so he goes to the Galapagos Islands,
and he has to find lots of
finches that're all very similar but not
identical, and by making comparisons of
the similarities and the differences you
then understand the essential properties
that led them to evolve as they did.
So we want to find the cousins of the
Riemann zeta function. To see whether
there are any, what might you do? Well you might look at this sum over the integers,
and you might change some of these plus
signs into minus signs and see, well,
can you have any combination of
pluses and minuses here? And it turns out
it's very rare that by changing some of
these plusses into minusses you can write
this sum, the resulting sum, as a product of the primes
but be slightly different to this product
but would resemble it. and you'd have something
that had a symmetry line that's very
very rare that that happens. to there is
one example of one. let me go back to the
Riemann zeta function going to split the
primes up into two classes: 2 will
always be special believe that is it is
but the odd primes
will either be - if you divide them
by 4 - either remainer of 1 or 3.
So you divide 3 by 4,
the remainders 3.
Divide 5 by 4
The remainder's 1. Because 5 is 4 + 1.
7: divide that by 4, uh the remainder is 3.
11 is 3. and 13 is 1.
So the ones that are divisible
where the remainder's 3 will flip their
sign, so we put that one there
We'll put a 1 there,
a 1 there, and we'll do the other 2.
And that gives you an L-function which has a symmetry
property to expand these products out
you get a sum of the integers exactly like the
Reiman Zeta function so this is an
example of a function which is an L-function.
a lot of these were discovered in the
nineteenth century. There are infinitely many
of them
BRADY: You said they were rare
Ya ya ya, um. despite the fact that there are many
they're extremely rare amongst all possible combinations of
plusses and minusses that you can have there.
So we know there are infinitely many other
functions that look like the Reimann Zeta function. you can write them as a sum
of the integers, you can write them as
a product of the primes - they have a
symmetry line - and we believe they all
have a Riemann hypothesis. So that was the
19th century then in the 20th century
people found other examples of
functions that have those properties you can write them as sums over the integers,
or products over the primes, they have a symmetry line, and we believe that they
a Reimann Hypothesis. And one of the heroes in this story's Ramanujan.
Sir Ramanujam was studying the following function:
X times (1- X) to the power of 24.
(1-X squared) to the power of 24.
times (1-X cubed) to power 24
times (1 - X to the 4th)^24 etc
you get the point and what he discovered
was that he could write this as a sum of
powers of X. (1 times X) minus (24
times X squared) you can do at home
multiply this thing out. that's 24 times X
squared plus 252 times X cubed minus
1472 times X power 4 etc...
and this keeps going on and you get these beautiful
whole numbers coming out now here's the miracle.
2 times 3 = 6
-24 times 252 = -6048. So these numbers have the
property that for example three times
five is 15 and if I go out to the 15th
number in this series
the the coefficient there,
the integer that appears is 252 times 4830.
This meant you could
associate an L-function with these
things. so here's what you do you write 1 - 24 over 2^s, +  252 over 3^s,
minus 1472 over 4^s, + 4830 over 5^s, et cetera and this series follows
from Ramanujan's observation a couple more observations that I won't sort of explain
in more detail it follows that you can
write this series as a product over
primes just as we did for the Riemann
zeta function you can plot that in the
complex plane and he has a symmetry line
exactly like the Riemann zeta function
does and the zeros of this function are
believed to satisfy Riemann hypothesis.
Now these functions are a class of functions called modular forms. They have certain
symmetry properties which we believe
give rise to the kinda general patterns
that you see in the Riemann zeta
function there is a symmetry line and
zeros on that line a Riemann hypothesis.
and these have been studied throughout the
twentieth century and Andrew Wiles in
his great work on Fermat's Last Theorem
used this connection between modular
forms that its functions like this and
L- functions that its functions like
this to proove Fermat's Last Theorem.
For all these L-functions we believe there's a
Riemann hypothesis so the big goal is to
say well can we find a pattern
can we see any similarities that would
give us a clue as to why the Riemann
Hypothesis is true, for any of them? and one of the things that's been done
recently is to produce a huge database
of millions of these L-functions with
all the properties tabulated in a very
clear and simple way and basically the
idea is to throw this out to the world
and say can you help us find the pattern?
and what you'll find there is the
Riemann zeta function, you'll find
Ramanujan's L- function, you'll find the
L functions that Andrew Wiles studied,
you'll find even more exotic and weird L-functions that we believe all have a
Riemann Hypothesis. and you go to this
website you find these zeros, you'll find plots of
these L-functions ... What's the pattern?
BRADY: if I go to this database though, I'm not gonna make a
breakthrough, am I? Surly this is only a resource for
mathematicians
Well...
It's originally for mathematicians, but I think
these properties are accessible to a
wide range of people this database is
set up so if you click on any technical
word, up comes an explanation of that word now you put some mathematics to
understand that but looking at the
pictures I something anyone can do and
somewhere in there is a pattern that
mathematicians haven't spotted. so it may
well be that somebody else spots it. not
likely but it is possible
too big for this the right knees
heavyset said it and I'll say it again
this is a prime between and into an
agreement did precisely that he
explained how to extend the this
function to all possible values except
for one so there's only one billion
there is nothing you can do